[Music]
tonight's confusion over the coronavirus
and classrooms as health officials take
a different approach to reopening our
schools thank you for joining us at six
i'm kirsten joy good evening i'm brian
loftis the southern nevada health
district saying they'll support
in-person instruction for ccsd students
even as we are seeing a new surge in
covet cases orco mana joins us live in
the newsroom after asking the health
district
directly why they are changing course
orco well brian and kirsten this is a
little bit of a surprise to school board
members and ccsd parents
for months the southern nevada health
district had been recommending
schools start reopening only when
certain coveted thresholds were met in
clark county
the health district telling me things
have changed because the mental health
of students
is also at stake if you make a decision
we will look for ways to support
the schools the southern nevada health
district changing course when it comes
to reopening classrooms amid covent 19.
acting chief health officer dr fermain
legane telling the ccsd board of
trustees thursday night he's ok with
in-person instruction for students
if that's what the school district
decides are you saying it's up to us
this comes as clark county is starting
to see a spike in covet 19
cases the most updated test positivity
rate is 9.6 percent
for months the health district
recommended a 5 percent positivity rate
and a 14 day downward trend in covet 19
cases before ccsd schools reopen
it's a balance but dr legane tells me
safety from the virus needs to be
weighed with the mental and behavioral
health impacts of distance learning some
students are being hit hard
the concerns about is suicide
among the younger population because of
this
isolation and also
the issue of even increasing the
the use of illegal drugs
but dr legane is making it clear strict
prevention measures will need to be
implemented by ccsd including social
distancing and mask wearing
it's not just opening the schools but
also
making sure that that there are
mitigation
activities in place parents tell us they
understand but they just want more
details from ccsd
what precautions and safety procedures
will there be
how will those be communicated how will
they be clearly enforced
important to note that two new
international medical studies show
no consistent relationship between
in-person k-12 schooling
and the spread of covid19 the ccsd board
of trustees has only been discussing
a potential return to the classroom via
a hybrid model
they are expected to vote on a plan that
includes some in-person instruction at
their november 12
meeting but right now there's still no
official timeline for when that can
happen chris gerson
thank you so much orco and the
washington post reports that 99.5
percent of schools that opened in the
fall
remain open without issue